bei debrezen in Ungarn treffen Ost und
West aufeinander bMW baut hier eine
E-Auto Fabrik Chinesen Stellen mehrere
batteriewerke daneben
Eva und anycue haben das Gefühl sie
werden dazwischen zerrieben
die wohnen im Nachbardorf
wir ziehen daraus keinen Nutzen
Ungarn hat keine Rohstoffe dafür die
Jobs besetzen Chinesen
die chinesische Fabrik verbraucht unser
Ackerland und unser Wasser
chinesischer Interessen in der EU immer
mehr chinesische Firmen bauen deshalb
hier
viele wären sich zunächst
Bürgerversammlung im Januar
Eva fragt warum die Zahlen zum
umweltverbrauch nicht öffentlich sind
der Regierungsvertreter
Verräter
[Applaus]
das war die letzte Bürgerversammlung sie
sind nun verboten auch eine
Volksabstimmung wurde nicht zugelassen
in den Medien würden sie nun als Agenten
fremder Mächte bezeichnet erzählen
anykül und Eva es waren hohesweise Inka
sei still hört zu macht deinen Job oben
entscheiden Sie was zu tun ist das ist
eine alte Mentalität die die Regierung
für sich nutzt
wer nicht auf Orban Linie ist wird
verleumdet das gilt auch in der
Weltpolitik
die Opposition sei Kriegspartei weil sie
für Russland Sanktionen ist
sogenannte Brüsseler Sanktionen
zerstörten Ungarn wird auf
regierungskosten propagiert
nicht nur ich als ungarischer premier
habe ein Problem mit Sanktionen sondern
die ganze Nationen
öfter allein
denn hier bremst er hier sagt er nein
wir müssen uns nicht nur gegen Migranten
wären sondern auch gegen Brüssel
eine andere EU und NATO pro russischer
nationalkonservativer und mit weniger
Kontrollen aus Brüssel
Orban einzubinden ist schwierig oder
teuer
die EU steht vor wichtigen
Entscheidungen die ohne Ungarn nicht
möglich sind wir werden keine Verlierer
sein
Budapest braucht Geld
2022 hatte Ungarn Rekord Inflation und
den höchsten Schuldenstand seit 30
Jahren die EU hält Milliarden zurück
wegen zu viel Korruption bekannt ist
dass in Ungarn Macht und Geld
zusammengehen sehr schnell sehr reich
wurden zum Beispiel Orbans Schwiegersohn
und der Freund aus Kinderheim weniger
bekannt ist das orban-system nun
ausländische Firmen ins Visier nimmt sie
sollen Ungarn reichern
es gibt Sektoren da stehen wir nicht gut
da Versicherung fernmelde-
Heidelberg Zement gehören zwei der drei
großen Werke in Ungarn mit
notstandsdekreten werden Ihnen immer
höhere Sondersteuern auferlegt sie
machen Minus und prompt kommt ein
Übernahmeangebot Zufall kein Kommentar
weder hier noch von der Regierung sicher
ist es geht vielen Branchen so
das geht dann immer so dass die
ungarische Regierung diesen Industrien
und in Firmen in diesen Industrien das
Leben sehr sehr schwer macht und
gleichzeitig kommen aus dem Umfeld der
Regierung
konzertien an deren Spitze meistens
landesbekannte Oligarchen stehen die
diesen Angebote diesen firmenangebote
machen zu Übernahme
Sondersteuern für Firmen mit
ausländischen Eignern
für uns Kasse und stärken aber uns macht
sie die deutsche Wirtschaft drängt
darauf dass die EU hier Werte schützt
insgesamt ist die Investitionssicherheit
elementar nicht nur gefährdet sondern
sondern betroffen so dass wir hier die
EU-Kommission aufgerufen fühlen wirklich
zu handeln
im Osten fragt keiner nach Schutz von
Eigentum und recht schon vor dem Krieg
wendet sich Orban Russland zu sein
Außenminister kümmert sich auch jetzt um
russische Interessen auch China wird
hofiert als wirtschaftliche und
machtpolitische alternative will Orban
der EU den Rücken kehren
Janus Hermann schließt das nicht aus er
hatte in Orbans erster Regierung hier im
Außenministerium gedient seitdem habe
Orban seine Sicht auf West und Ost
verändert
dass der Westen Einfluss verlieren wird
dass die westliche Hegemonie in
Osteuropa langfristig nicht zu halten
ist
gut Stellen mit den östlichen Mächten
mit China aber auch mit Russland
wirtschaftlich und politisch will Orban
profitieren wenn sich chinesische Firmen
nicht nur in debrezeln ansiedeln
versucht sie weiter dagegen zu
mobilisieren
man kann nichts dagegen machen
doch man kann noch
doch sie hat einen Plan B wenn es gar
nicht mehr geht will sie auswandern in
den Westen da wohnt schon ihre drei
Kinder
[Musik]